arch rivalries aren't just the stuff of
computer games the gaming industry is
now worth more than 60 billion bucks and
it's only growing fighting for a piece
of the action are two of the world's
biggest tech companies we want to be at
the center of your living room eager
Americans can get their hands on Sony's
brand new PlayStation today microsoft
launches the new xbox november the 22nd
who's got the edge on game powering
alone ps4 may take the prize it's
smaller than the new xbox yet packs more
powerful graphics drivers but winning
over the hardcore gamer who on average
is 30 years old is only part of the
battle both consoles want to capture
whole families to be there all-in-one
entertainment solution each allows you
to play dvds and access the web and
on-demand video but the xbox takes it a
step further allowing you to watch live
TV it will also recognize you and your
gestures a potentially big draw with a
younger crowd on the PlayStation 4
that's an extra what about the price
well the PlayStation is a hundred bucks
cheaper analysts say that may tip the
scale in its favor let the games begin
Ryan Chilcote Bloomberg